mes chers amis je confirme je ne lis pas
d'iphones et d'ailleurs je trouve que ce
formidable outil de communication ne
pouvait pas discuter avec quelqu'un sans
qu'ils soient menées sur son écran moi
je trouve quand on est avec les gens on
les écoute on s'écoute
merci avais je n'ai pas de réserves sur
le bon usage et j'aimerais d'ailleurs
qu'un certain nombre d'entreprises
publiques se souviennent qu elles ont
des usagers qui doivent être respectées
je crois que le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas
respectées merci à tous ceux qui ont
contribué à cette journée
le travail sur les idées est
indispensable je remercie notamment eric
woerth le secrétaire général et isabelle
qu'elle aimait notre vice présidente
il y à une telle attente une telle
attente des français sur l'alternance
sur la clarté sur la force de cette
alternance observons les fractures à
gauche observons la vigueur du mouvement
social en cours contre ce gouvernement
les malheurs de ce gouvernement
les échecs multiples de françois
hollande doivent nous servir à nous
l'opposition républicaine
car la désespérance des français en
cause et cette cause ce sont les
mensonges du candidat socialiste pendant
la campagne présidentielle il faut t'y
revenir
parce que c'est la clé les synthèses
immo liantes où personne ne comprend
rien les artifices de communication qui
n'ont qu'un temps les rideaux de fumée
envoyé à l'opinion publique n'y change
rien
la colère gronde la désespérance
augmente et les françaises demandent
tout simplement si la france encore un
avenir
face à cela les mots clés pour nous
doivent être la clarté la vérité le
courage parce qu'au bout de la clarté de
la vérité du courage il ya la confiance
et on ne répondra pas aux mensonges de
la gauche dit hier par les mensonges de
la droite aujourd'hui ou même des
approximations ou même des
approximations tout dire avant pour tout
faire après il n'y a pas d'autre
stratégie possible
il n'ya pas d'autre stratégie possible
d'un point de vue démocratique et
politique mais y'a pas d'autre stratégie
possible également d'un point de vue
moral
un parti politique qui n'aurait pas un
projet politique fort ne serait pas un
parti politique
donc la question est tranchée nous
allons continuer à réfléchir à
travailler et au mois de juin les
républicains auront un projet
d'alternance merci à jacques alain
bénisti merci eric ciotti merci arnaud
viala quand tu participes à dix mes skis
parisiens ou pas
merci à valérie d'abord merci à eric
berdoati merci à gilles v ous sur le
maire merci à tous ceux qui ont dépassé
les difficultés francilienne preuve s'il
en est de l'utilité du service minimum
dans les transports en commun comme
avait tellement rentrer chez vous en
souvenez on nous l'avait approché mais
ça marche
alors pour commencer je ne veux pas
qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté entre nous ça
doit être clair madame la directrice
générale adjointe du medef entende est
le bien
la france a besoin d'un état fort je ne
veux pas qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté entre
nous j'ai dit pas d'approximation pas de
faciliter la france a besoin d'un état
fort et les fonctionnaires ont le droit
à notre considération
il ya notre respect je dois dire deux
choses la france s'est bâtie autour de
son état qui a joué un rôle décisif dans
sa cohésion et dans son unité
autant je suis convaincu de la nécessité
de laisser de la souplesse la liberté
aux départements et aux régions
quand je veux rappeler que les
républicains parlent à la nation
française dans son ensemble
nous ne sommes pas un état fédéral et
nous n'avons pas l'intention de le
devenir sur les fonctionnaires jeu qu'on
met les points sur les i à chaque crise
à chaque catastrophe
à chaque événement qui vient frapper
notre pays nos compatriotes savent
qu'ils peuvent compter sur une fonction
publique dont l'immense majorité est
compétente et passionné et dévoué
quand on a vu
la mobilisation des services publics au
moment du drame du bataclan chez rona
championnat quand on a vu le drame de
charlie quand on a vu le drame du super
cacher à chaque fois il ya des services
publics des hommes et les femmes qui ont
été présents je ne veux pas qu'on les
mette en cause car notre idée c'est la
modernisation de la fonction publique
par l'opposition à la fonction publique
et fonctionnaires de france ont toute
leur place dans le projet politique est
une autre et quand tu les tempêtes les
xynthia les drames on est bien content y
compris le dimanche matin de trouver des
fonctionnaires qui sont là pour dégager
la voirie pour porter secours à ceux qui
souffrent ou pour aller chercher des
gens qui sont isolés au milieu d'une
inondation
je veux vraiment que ça soit clair parce
qu'au fond notre parti politique a une
spécificité nous devons parler à tout le
monde et l'alternance tous deux vont
rassembler le plus grand nombre parce
que les changements à faire seront
tellement profond qu'on ne changera pas
avec une minorité on changera avec une
immense majorité donc que les
fonctionnaires nous entende
nous avons des choses à leur dire et la
première c'est la nécessité de la
lucidité sur la situation actuelle
il faut être lucide notre fonction
publique ne va pas bien et il ya une
chose qui nous est interdit c'est le
statu quo le statu quo n'est pas tenable
ce n'est pas une question de droite ou
de gauche ce n'est pas une question
idéologique 57 % de la richesse de la
nation passent dans des dépenses
publiques ce qui fait porter un poids 1
sur portable sur les agents privés
entreprises artisans commerçants
donc ce n'est pas une question d'
alternatives la question n'est pas de
savoir est-ce qu'il faut changer les
choses ou pas si on veut sauver le
système
il faut
le refonder c'est d'autant plus
important d'avoir cette lucidité que la
france qui est le pays d'europe qui a
les plus grandes dépenses publiques est
le seul qui trouve le moyen depuis 2012
d'augmenter les effectifs de
fonctionnaires non seulement il y avait
trop de dépenses publiques
non on trouve le moyen d'être allé seul
à augmenter les effectifs
avec ce concept assez ahurissant
socialiste de stabilité globale
si quelqu'un capable de comprendre ce
que ça veut dire la stabilité globale
oui ça veut dire ça mensonge en 2016 le
gouvernement va accroître de 8000 le
nombre de fonctionnaires comme si la
france pouvait se le permettre alors je
veux dénoncer cette idée fausse en
augmentant le nombre de fonctionnaires
on augmente la qualité du service public
nous sommes pour un service public de
qualité et nous disons sherjill au
moment de l'explosion du numérique qu'il
n'y a aucune raison d'être condamné à ce
principe
faux on augmente le nombre de
fonctionnaires on augmenterait ainsi la
qualité du service public
c'est le choix que nous avons faits de
2007 à 2012 pardon d'y revenir
nous avons supprimé 150 mille postes de
fonctionnaires la cour des comptes a
chiffré l'économie c'est la cour des
comptes à 4 milliards 200 millions
on peut parfaitement me direz j'entends
cet argument ce n'était pas assez
simplement permettez moi de répondre que
dans l'histoire de la république
c'est la seule fois qu'un président de
la république a conduit à la diminution
des effectifs dans la fonction publique
de l'état
ça c'est la vérité cette vérité
incontournable
ça ne veut pas dire chaque lot jerry que
c'est suffisant mais ça veut dire que
personne ni à gauche ni à droite ne
l'avait fait avant donc la première idée
que nous voulons tous défendre il faut
recommencer
non remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur
deux à l'exception des services de
sécurité compte tenu de la menace
terroriste qui a explosé par rapport à
ce qu'elle était à ce qu'elle était il
ya quelques années mais le grand
changement sur lequel nous nous
engageons le grand c'est que nous
voulons réformer la constitution pour
imposer la règle du non-remplacement de
1 sur 2 aux collectivités territoriales
car c'est vrai qu'à l'époque 95% des
régions était à gauche 70% des
départements était à gauche
dans le même temps réduisent f150 mais
les effectifs de l'état les
collectivités territoriales à gauche les
augmenter d'autant la question peut se
poser et toute manière ces mêmes on en a
débattu
est-ce qu'on peut aller plus loin que la
sur deux j'entends pour moi non je vais
m'en expliquer parce que si vous bloquez
tout recrutement dans un corps vous
garderez forcément les plus âgés et pas
forcément les plus dynamiques
oui selon une règle c'est qu'en général
ce dont ne veut pas ailleurs vous les
garder réfléchissez c'est très complexe
que je dis mais c'est assez juste et
surtout charneau cherche à canal
si on supprime toute forme de
recrutement à ce moment-là vous bloquer
toutes les écoles de formation
ceux qui disent faut arrêter pendant
deux ou trois ans parfait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des écoles de formation des
formateurs on recommence après donc
l'objectif pour nous c'est de supprimer
sur le quinquennat entre 300 mille trois
cent cinquante mille postes de
fonctionnaires ce qui est pas une petite
affaire parce que les mêmes qui vous
demandent de supprimer le nombre de
fonctionnaires de diminuer le nombre de
fonctionnaires au collectif seront les
premiers à vous dire oui mais dans mon
département et une école oui mais dans
mon hôpital il ya quelqu'un oui mais bon
ça c'est l'objectif que nous avons c'est
le premier qui consiste à réduire les
dépenses publiques
je n'avance second jeu comme entendent
bien là dessus c'est celui de l'égalité
l'égalité c'est un mot qu'on sort à
toutes les choses en général pour en
faire de l'égalitarisme du nivellement
je veux reprendre ce mot pour dire que
nous ne pouvons pas accepter les
différences de traitement entre le
secteur public et secteur privé c'est
une question de cohésion nationale la
refondation de la fonction publique doit
donc reposer sur le principe d'équité
entre le public et le privé ce qui peut
se traduire par des décisions précises
la première nous allons faire converger
le public et le privé sur la retraite
cela veut donc dire 63 ans dès 2020 64
ans dès 2025 et que dans le public on ne
calculera plus le montant de la pension
sur les six derniers mois
mais comme dans le privé sur les 25
meilleures années
il ne s'agit pas de sanctionner il ne
s'agit pas de punir
il s'agit de donner vie un principe qui
est inscrit sur le frontispice de tous
nos équipements publics liberté
fraternité et égalité ce qui va nous
conduire dans le même mouvement à
supprimer les régimes spéciaux de
retraite pour les basculer vers le
régime général de retraite
là aussi j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
sur le système des gaziers des
électriciens blanc cndf
je rappelle que jusqu'en 2007
personne absolument personne ne s'était
attaqué à la réforme des régimes
spéciaux de retraite c'est le
gouvernement de 2007 qui les a réformé
pour applications 2000
16 ce qui a valu neuf jours de blocage
généralisé et quand nous avons fait la
réforme chère et des retraites de 2010
nous avons appliqué les mêmes deux
années de travailler plus sans augmenter
les pensions de retraite aux régimes
spéciaux
là encore je tout à fait prêts à prendre
toutes les critiques qui font nadia
plutôt plus fort simplement en vertu de
ce proverbe que j'aime beaucoup
quand je me suis tu je m'inquiète quand
je me compare je me rassure je rappelle
personne ni à gauche ni à droite ne
s'était jamais attaqué aux régimes
spéciaux de retraite
nous allons dans le cas de l'alternance
les supprimer je continue nous avions
rétabli le jour de carence dans la
fonction publique
qu'est ce que c'est que le jour de
carence quand vous avez un arrêt maladie
le première journée on la rembourse pas
cette mesure a été abrogée dès 2013 et
dans le même temps ont disparu de la
publication des indicateurs de la
fonction publique
l'absentéisme car naturellement comme
c'est extraordinaire avec le jour de
carence on a vu diminution de
l'absentéisme
oui ben sylla premier jour d'absence est
pas payé sa défaire procès à personne
que dire parfois il ya des tentations et
bien le lait la carence et trois jours
dans le privé madame la directrice
il est vrai que souvent les entreprises
en achète un dire ça c'est je crois être
précis dans les dossiers donc en moyenne
faut être toujours être précis même au
medef
alors c'est ma manière d'être
chaleureuse et dire que par moment parce
que par moments on entend des choses
donc pour nous après m'avoir débattu ces
deux jours de carence qui sont
appliquées en vertu du même principe
l'égalité
l'égalité c'est également des règles de
gestion du public comparable à celle du
privé
je vous le dis comme je le pense
les jours de congé entre le secteur
public et le secteur privé doivent être
alignés
car à travail égal les fonctionnaires
publics doivent avoir un traitement égal
aux travailleurs du privé
pareil pour le dialogue social interne
je vous le dis comme je le pense nous
voulons refonder démocratie sociale qui
ne marche plus du tout supprimer le
monopole de présentation premier tour
supprimer des délégués syndicaux qui
seraient nommés par des centrales
syndicales
alors même qu'ils ont été battus aux
élections dans l'entreprise et bien ce
qui se passe dans privé doit se passer
également dans le public il faut au fond
rompre avec une forme de cogestion avec
les organisations syndicales de services
administratifs et de la carrière des
agents parce que que ce soit les
syndicats qui annoncent nomination à
l'éducation nationale c'est un
détournement de l'esprit même du service
public
alors au delà de ce principe l'égalité
il ya me semble-t-il la question de la
modernisation de la fonction publique
ici deux logiques s'opposent pas le
courage de poser sa devant les cinq
millions de fonctionnaires français et
leurs familles
la première logique celle du statu quo
aboutira à la paupérisation de la
fonction publique
comment faire croire aux fonctionnaires
qui seront demain mieux considérer mieux
respectés mieux rémunérés si nous
n'engageons
aucun effort alors que la france coule
sur les déficits et sur l'endettement
et puis il ya notre ambition qui est
celle de la modernisation avec un
discours de vérité qui s'imposent
on est en droit de poser la question à
quoi ont servi les 60000 recrutement
l'éducation nationale qu'avait annoncé
françois hollande en 2012
c'est ce que l'école fonctionne mieux
est ce que les enseignants sont plus
heureux est-ce qu'il ya plus
d'enseignants au contact de vos enfants
jarno sk - d'école en ruralité qui ferme
où est passé l'argent des français
le secteur public et je partage cette
opinion avec hervé doit améliorer son
organisation et pour cela je dis les
mots comme elle son devoir de vérité
pour créer de la confiance
nous allons augmenter le temps de
travail des fonctionnaires ce qui
signifie que les règles qui organise le
temps de travail dans la fonction
publique
je parle de tout ce que sont les accords
jospin 2000 et les accords aubry seront
remises à plat la première chose que
nous ferons c'est que les français sont
en droit d'attendre des services publics
qui tous soient au moins aux 35 heures
ce qui n'est pas le cas et je veux
rendre hommage à eric ciotti qui
engageait le conseil départemental des
alpes maritimes dans cette voie
courageuse les français pensent que la
fonction publique et aux 35 heures ici à
la tribune ou dans la salle
vous êtes innombrables à savoir que ce
n'est pas le cas certains surtout 32
heures d'autres sont à 28 heures nous
demandons l'effectivité des 35 heures
pour tous les services publics
ce n'est pas tout je propose que la
liberté soit rendu à tous les exécutifs
territoriaux mer
présidente départements de région de
discuter avec leur personnel de
l'allongement de la durée de travail au
delà des 35 heures avec la liberté
notamment d'accorder des heures
supplémentaires mais comme pour le
secteur privé
nous ne posons qu'une seule condition
chaque heure travaillée en plus des 35
heures doit être rémunéré moi je suis
désolé je n'ai pas changé je ne suis pas
pour le travailler plus et gagner moins
non que les choses soient claires aussi
entre nous on ne rase des bye pas de
problème mais c'est pas les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres je dis bien au delà des
35 heures pas pour passer de 32 à 35
alors concernant l'état notre
proposition c'est que les fonctionnaires
d'état doivent travailler 37 heures
hebdomadaires payées 37 et sur la base
du volontariat des agents dans les
services de l'état le temps de travail
hebdomadaire pourrait être poussée
jusqu'à 39 heures payées 39
donc en résumé tout le monde au minimum
aux 35 heures remise à plat des accords
jospin des années 2000 et des accords
aubry pour l'état on passe à 37 heures
pays 37 pour les collectivités
territoriales liberté de négocier soit
des heures supplémentaires soit une
augmentation de temps de travail pour
décider que les heures supplémentaires
par exemple comment se classe 37e et
pour les services de l'état sur la base
du volontariat
on ouvrira pour aller au delà 37 eur
naturellement si ces 38 jean françois
houle 39 c 38 ou 39 et 38 ou 39
est-ce que c'est clair et c'est très
important je dis parce que on est
conscient de la bim des déficits la
nécessité de réduire les dépenses
publiques
on est conscient de la nécessité de
moderniser la fonction publique
mais nous voulons dire aux
fonctionnaires qu'on fait ça parce qu'on
respecte le travail parce qu'on a besoin
leur travail et naturellement si on
supprime 300 mille postes de
fonctionnaires et qu'on n'augmente pas
les heures de travail ça naturellement
ça pèsera à un moment donné sur la
qualité du service public
vous l'avez compris moins de
fonctionnaires mieux payés pour un
meilleur service public avec des
réductions des dépenses publiques le 30
mars et eric après l'excellente décision
de faire une journée
joli travail sur l'économie sur la
fiscalité
vous voyez que il y avait une arrière
pensée par ces conventions d'aujourd'hui
on préfère commencer par parler des
économies pour parler des baisses
d'impôts après parce que la crédibilité
des baisses d'impôts elle est fonction
de la réelle sera fonction de la réalité
des économies
un mot pour les enseignants on fera une
convention un chemin sur l'éducation
nationale et c'est toute la difficulté
de notre travail aujourd'hui il fallait
très précis et en même temps on peut pas
tout embrasser donc juste un mot sur les
enseignants parce que on en parlera dans
la convention sur l'éducation nationale
mais les obligations de service puisque
c'est en terme d'obligation de service
circuit à mon souvenir maternelle
primaire 24 heures par semaine
à mon souvenir pour les enseignants
certifiés 18h en collège et en lycée et
à mon souvenir pour les agrégés
15h06 mois de l'année
non je savais je perds de nombreux
enfants j'admire le travail des
enseignants parce que je suis pas sûr
que j'aurais toujours la patience l'envi
la gentillesse la pédagogie mais
simplement dans nos collèges et dans nos
lycées le problème est centrale c'est
qui a pas assez d'adultes
donc l'idée qui est la nôtre c'est
d'augmenter de 25% le temps de présence
des enseignants dans les collèges dans
les lycées de vos enfants mais non pas
hervé pour augmenter le nombre de
classes d'heures de classe pour
augmenter la présence des adultes dans
l'école pour être à la disposition de
ceux de vos enfants qui n'arrivent pas à
suivre
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens de
payer des petits courts d'avoir des
cours de rattrapage où tout le monde n'a
pas à la maison des parents disponibles
pour faire faire le travail des enfants
donc l'idée n'est pas d'augmenter les
heures de classe de vos enfants mais
l'idée c'est d'augmenter assez
massivement la présence des adultes dans
les collèges et dans les lycées pour
soutenir les enfants qui ont du mal à
suivre bien sûr dans cette promotion on
parlera dans l'augmentation du
traitement des enseignants
un mot sur les les fonctionnaires
hospitaliers puisque comme vous le savez
il ya trois fonctions publiques
aujourd'hui j'y reviendrai la fonction
d'état la fonction territoriale et la
fonction hospitalière
je veux dire un mot un eric si tu me
permets parce que on n'en parle pas là
dedans parce que c'est particulier
l'ancienne infirmière qui cloue greffe
qui me regardait déjà avec des yeux sont
parlé de bérangère là je me semble je me
sens bien l'encadrer sûr nous n'avons
pas parlé de le temps de travail dans
l'hôpital parce que quand nous ferons la
convention santé je proposerai aux
républicains de faire un saut d'une
importance considérable qui consistera
donner l'autonomie à nos hôpitaux comme
nous avons donné le tonneau
à nos universités et naturellement vous
voyez ce qu'il ya derrière
si vous donner l'autonomie c'est pour
donner de la liberté
et si vous commencez à dire la liberté
je vais l'encadrer
à ce moment là ça ne va plus on aura
l'occasion d'en parler et de développer
cela je voulais juste le dire d'un mot
le statut de la fonction publique
là aussi vieux serpent de mer je vous
annonce qu'il ne restera pas en l'état
nous portons la même ambition sur le
statut de la fonction publique que celle
que nous portons madame la directrice
sur la réforme du code du travail
parce que le statut des fonctionnaires
qui devait à l'origine protéger les
fonctionnaires des aléas de l'arbitraire
devient aujourd'hui un carcan inefficace
qui bloque la performance et qui à
vouloir protéger tout le monde finit par
pénaliser chacun c'est ça la vérité nous
allons donc proposer un statut général
de la fonction publique de refonder mans
remaniée au fond il y aura deux
catégories dans la fonction publique la
première sont des fonctionnaires qui ont
un statut ce statut leur permettra de
rester fonctionnaires toute la vie avec
un changement nous voulons la fin de
l'impunité
quand on fait pas bien son travail on
doit pouvoir est expulsé de son statut
on ne peut pas s'abriter derrière un
statut
je n'ai pas d'ambiguïté entre nous il ya
des métiers
moi en tout cas c'est mon opinion qui
ont sont des métiers particuliers je
pense aux forces de sécurité
je pense aux enseignants je pense même à
quelque chose comme est en peau et
d'état civil parce que c'est pas rien et
d'ailleurs on échoue le double contrôle
sherjill du maire et du procureur de la
république et je ne vois pas pourquoi le
statut de fonctionnaire serait remis en
cause mais dont les élus vous le diront
le statut de fonctionnaire sert parfois
à masquer les insuffisances
professionnelles graves à l'abri d'un
statut définitif
l'impunité c'est terminé et pour tous
les métiers
aujourd'hui par exemple dans ta commune
à châteauroux les parcs et jardins
l'ingénieur la voirie et bien nous
permettront à toutes les administrations
nationales comme locales de recourir aux
contrats contrats qui obéira aux mêmes
règles que le contrat privé parce que je
me méfie trop de la jurisprudence des
tribunaux et de la capacité de
l'administration française à digérer les
réformes on va pas faire un vol a pu qu
il y aura le statut des fonctionnaires
puis rencontre à ça sera le même
le même contrat du privé le même contrat
du public pour normes et dans le temps
pour le renouveler pas le renouveler et
on verra si du un des contrats à durée
déterminée ou indéterminée
ce serait la même chose en vérité c'est
une très bonne idée d'eric woerth
nous voulons passer d'une fonction
publique au fond des corps au profit
d'une fonction publique des métiers
quand j'étais devenu jeune ministre du
budget y est bien longtemps j'avais été
super fait d'apprendre que pour passer
de la comptabilité publique à la djs
saleh à un concours
la dg quelques l'impôt la comptabilité
publique le père soir
il fallait un concours la logique de
corps absurde remarque et depuis je suis
devenu président de la république et
nous avons fusionné la compatibilité
tabilité public et la dg par parenthèse
trois ministres socialistes avaient
quitté le gouvernement en échouant cette
réforme que nous avons conduits chéri
sans l'ombre d'un problème mais en
vérité un fonctionnaire qui rentre dans
la fonction publique
il devrait pouvoir épouser beaucoup de
métier parce que scherno ça facilite la
mobilité cher jacques alain s y compris
la mobilité entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'état
je n'accepte plus cette espèce de deux
au fond snobisme
il ya un corps d'état tisserait
prestigieux décor des collectivités
territoriales qui ne le serait pas je
trouve que quelqu'un qui est compétent
pour exercer dans une pile de pouvoir
être compétent pour exercer dans une
administration centrale et vice et versa
ce qui permettrait de créer de la
mobilité de faciliter la vie des
fonctionnaires
suivant un conjoint ou une conjointe
étant entendu que nous précisons quelque
chose c'est que les directeurs
d'administration centrale dans
l'alternance seront d'accord avec la
politique nouvelle qui devra s'appliquer
nous ne serons plus directeurs
d'administration centrale ya un problème
de loyauté d'un problème clarté d'un
problème légitime un mot sur les
rémunérations des agents titulaires de
la fonction publique
alors là la rémunération actuelle
correspond à une accumulation de couches
toutes plus extravagantes de complexité
traitement indiciaire bonification
indemnités que toute nature personne n'y
comprend rien sauf que que vous
travaillez beaucoup vous travaillez pas
du tout
le résultat est exactement le même alors
nous voulons des fonctionnaires qui
n'est plus à subir ce millefeuille et
nous voulons organiser un nouveau régime
de rémunération des fonctionnaires
autour de trois volets le premier
liée au grave de l'agent puisque la
république c'est quand même des concours
et c'est normal le deuxième volet sur et
fonctionnelles liées au métier de
l'agent et le troisième volet de
rémunération répondrait à la performance
de l'agent c'est à dire à son évaluation
up
j'écoutais je sais bien que j'étais
ministre intérieur j'avais fait ça et tu
te souviens j'avais été accusés entre
autres choses entre autres choses de
mettre une pression insupportable sur
mon administration
enfin milices et intérieure qui met pas
la pression sur l'administration il à se
coucher où ils partent en vacances et
fait ce qu'il veut mais théoriquement
c'est comme si on me disait le président
des rébus canaux pas bête la pression
pour qu'on travaille ça c'est possible
je peux ne pas mettre la pression d'un 2
ce cas là le résultat on a vu comment
c'était les républicains qu'il n'y ait
pas la pression positive
moi je crois à la pression je fais pas
être du pain et eric vous avez pour en
porter témoignage de si on n'est pas là
tous les jours si on nous mêmes on
demande pas si même le teil amusante si
on fixe pas la date de la convention la
convention dans six mois on n'a pas
toujours pas donc oui mais on n'est pas
prêt ah oui mais si on fixe une date on
est obligé d'être prêt enfin je pense je
pourrais multiplier les exemples
les hauts-fonds l'idée des républicains
c'est que le mérite redevienne une
valeur républicaine c'est que l'effort
soit récompensé c'est qui est une
récompense et tout le monde connaît dans
sa ville des fonctionnaires toujours
volontaire et des fonctionnaires jamais
volontaire
tout le monde connaît dans l'école de
ses enfants des enseignements des
enseignants du dévouement exceptionnel
où les familles se battent pour avoir
l'école et d'autres où l'absentéisme est
permanent comme si ça tombait toujours
sur les mêmes et mais il s'agit de
valoriser ceux qui aiment leur métier
qui se donne du mal
et de sanctionner ceux qui ne
considèrent pas que métier de
fonctionnaire crée des obligations alors
il y aurait bien d'autres choses à dire
mais je pète trop long et un troisième
volet auquel je tiens beaucoup je sais
que c'est un risque donc parler mes
parents quand même c'est celui du
rapport entre les citoyens
l'administration
là on est arrivé à un point qui est
insupportable et pas simplement à cause
des normes bien sûr et non mais l'esprit
avec lesquels ces normes sont appliquées
nous sommes dans une république et une
régie publique de la défiance de la
méfiance et de la détestation de tous
par tous nous voudrions rentrer dans la
république de la confiance où on voit
l'administration comme un conseil comme
un orientateur comme un facilitateur
camps puissent se dire quand on se pose
une question chefs d'entreprises ou
particuliers qui en baisse je vais aller
voir mon le l'inspecteur je lui ai
demandé son avis je vais essayer de voir
si c'est possible ou l'administration
est autant un rôle de médiateur carole
de sanctions
je vais me dire ça c'est des bonnes
idées mais il faut les faire rentrer
dans des propositions précises et bien
nous les avons tout à l'heure on parlait
du numérique sherjill un détail
si nous avions le même taux déclaration
de l'impôt sur le revenu par le
numérique que la moyenne de le céder 1
on pourrait immédiatement supprimé 1000
emplois au sein des services fiscaux
français par exemple quelque chose
d'extraordinaire simplement en étant à
la moyenne des télédéclarations
numérique de l' ocde
s'agissant des contrôles alors là il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
moi je suis désolé un chef d'entreprise
il est chez lui il ya particulier chez
lui je souhaite que les contrôles dans
l'entreprise chez les particuliers
deviennent
exception et non pas la règle un chef
d'entreprise a autre chose à faire que
recevoir une harde d'une escouade de
contrôleurs qui viennent le dire
monsieur je suis madame je suis chez moi
ici
non loin s'installe pendant plusieurs
mois
block un bureau et bloquent des
collaborateurs nous souhaitons que les
contrôles soient des contrôles sur
pièces sherjill à l'époque du numérique
ça doit quand même être facile organisé
et que les contrôles sur place ne soit
autorisée que dans la mesure où
l'administration aurait des éléments
concrets précis de suspicion d'une
fraude
je rappelle la présomption c'est que les
citoyens les usagers soient réputés
honnête et que ce qu'on s'a que
l'administration se consacre sur les
malhonnêtes et sur les fraudeurs
s'agissant du même principe
nous proposons que les contrôles soient
réservés sur la seule année précédant
l'année en cours c'est à dire qu'on
passerait d'un système de prescription
trois ans plus l'année en cours à 1 en
plus l'année en cours sauf naturellement
s'il ya des éléments précis de suspicion
de fraude
vous voyez le changement considérable
alors il y aurait des tas d'autres
exemples je ne suis pas persuadé voyez
vous que la police de l'eau doit être
armés
on voit un paysan d'agriculteur va
arriver personne armée pour contrôler
l'écoulement de l'étang sur
l'exploitation
bon si les gens on a besoin d'armes
il ya peut-être d'autres secteurs on
pourrait les orienter où on manque
d'effectifs et on aurait peut-être
besoin je dis la même chose pour les
contrôles dans les exploitations
agricoles annoncé une jolie musique on
peut on pourrait avoir pour les
exploitations agricoles également je
n'ai jamais vu le monde de l'agriculture
dans un tel état de désespérance
parce que vous imaginez ce que cela
produit sur un agriculteur qui voit les
cours s'effondrent et que de voir des
contrôles à uhry sens d'une certaine
violence même morale et c'est donc tout
un changement dans les rapports entre
l'administration et les citoyens que
nous voulons porter au fond
l'administration pourrait remplir un
rôle de tiers garant conseil et garantit
des accords ou de facilitateur
exactement comme matière de rupture
conventionnelle
l'administration doit être capable de
répondre avec une réponse opposable dès
lors qu'elle dispose du pouvoir de
prendre une décision administrative
c'est à dire un rescrit d'un rescrit
social ou un rescrit fiscal
et puis moi je suis désolé si
l'administration répond pas on doit
pouvoir être protégé ça veut dire
qu'elle est d'accord et la présomption
doit être la présomption d'innocence
ce que vous avez dit hervé dorothée sur
les normes qui doivent avoir un terme
j'adhère complètement sur l'évaluation
j'adhère complètement sur le refus de la
sueur transposition j'adhère
complètement et je vous propose même une
règle encore plus simple que la france
n'accepte aucune norme qui soit
supérieur à la norme européenne
voilà qu'à partir de ce moment là on
rentre en studio et je vous propose une
deuxième règle que chaque fois qui est
une norme supplémentaires on s'engage à
supprimer deux anciennes et d'ailleurs
ce que vous proposez sur les normes
je pense que on aurait tout intérêt à le
faire aussi sur les mesures fiscales ce
qui nous permettrait de les évaluer
parce que parfois il ya même des
représentants des entreprises qui nous
demandent des avantages fiscaux dans le
bâtiment bon et quand le dictateur les
votes ça reste quinze ans as vingt ans
plus personne ne sait à quoi ça sert ça
fait partie de l'acquis l'idée que des
niches fiscales soit normes et dans le
temps soit borné dans le temps pour
obliger à l'évaluation me semble être
une très bonne idée
voilà mesdames et messieurs valérie mes
chers amis valérie de bord va lire les
questions qui vont vous être soumis je
vous comprenez bien l'état d'esprit qui
est le nôtre nous sommes conscients de
la gravité de la situation de la france
nous allons donc à chaque fois au plus
loin que nous pensons utile pour
redresser le pays
mais avec un souci c'est que ça se fasse
je me méfie beaucoup des grandes
enflammé qui ne se produisent pas de
grandes déclarations enflammées qui ne
se traduisent pas rien et par ailleurs
nous veillons à ce que ce soit des
propositions sur le quinquennat qui
vient je préfère ça à des propositions
pour les deux ou trois quinquennats qui
viennent
voilà je sens que vous avez parfaitement
compris de quoi il s'agissait
enfin dernier point j'estime que ce que
nous avons proposé là c'est solide
c'est fort c'est sérieux et ce n'est pas
un programme idéologique
la question n'est pas de savoir si on
est libéral conservateur de droite
la question c'est que nous sommes des
français passionnés de la france qui
voulons redresser la france et c'est ça
peut encore en tout cas
gervais quand on a vocation à rassembler
toute la famille et même toute
l'opposition
je pense que la france beaucoup souffert
de l'idéologie de combat d'une autre
époque et qu'elle doit maintenant
regarder la situation avec lucidité et
un esprit de vérité c'est le seul moyen
possible dans un pays de plus de 60
millions d'habitants qui a en lui une
telle énergie et parfois une telle
violence et ça fait un peu de peine de
voir quand on parle la modernisation du
code du travail qui seront combien
nécessaire on va agir agité des lycéens
qui ne sont pas forcément les mieux
placés pour savoir ce qui convient de
faire en matière d'emploi de gestion
d'entreprise ou d'évolution du code du
travail
hier cela c'est respecter les lycéens
qui dans mon esprit sont mieux qu'une
marge de manoeuvre utilisé par des
conservateurs qui plonge le pays dans
une crise dont ils ne se redressera pas
voilà la vérité c'était la vérité à
l'époque d'edouard balladur
c'était la vérité à l'époque de
dominique de villepin
quand j'ai connu les affrontements au
moment de l'autonomie des universités
j'avais dit aux étudiants
vous pouvez manifester je ne céderai pas
parce que l'autonomie des universités
c'est la garantie
de votre avenir je vous remercie